l'homme aux yeux d'argent de pierre a
nié de faire c'est le nouveau film
l'événement même de la semaine d'abord
parce qu'il s'agit d'un film policier
pas comme les autres de l'aveu même de
son réalisateur
c'est un divertissement sans message est
sans aucune prétention
en revanche lorsqu'on regarde de
génériques et la performance des acteurs
jean louis trintignant alain souchon
tania lopez on sait que ce film relève
de la nouvelle offensive des acteurs de
notre cinéma on croit de nouveau et le
public en daim à preuve un cinéma fait
de performances d'acteur
on remarquera donc un changement de ton
dans ce film est aussi une parfaite
connaissance de l'air du temps les
choses ont changé la morale n'est plus
la même
l'attitude du public non plus et voilà
pourquoi ce film de gagner de faire
n'est pas juste un petit produit de
consommation rien trouvé
j'ai pris des risques bien
un matin je vais vous montrer où est
l'argent où il est vraiment c'est ici
que j'avais laissé l'argent sa part là
vous vous souvenez il y avait une ferme
à ferme de mes parents
où est l'argent berger l'a enterré
quelque part on a fait creuser partout
partout les six hectares
j'avais trouvé un endroit facile à
reconnaître pour moi et voilà dans les
films c'est comme ça il y en a toujours
un auquel on doit s'attacher alors moi
je suis personnage ap londres
s'attachait tandis qu'à trintignant on
doit lui on doit pas les met dans le
screen pays bon il fait une prestation
magnifique dans ce film jean louis et
oui je suis le personnage que j'aime
bien ça on s'attache comme ça ce
personnage qu'il est le rapport entre la
création côté chanson et le cinéma et
c'est un complément un contrepoint c'est
quoi pour vous pour vous à l'instruction
j'adore le faire de l'acteur je trouve
que c'est un mécanisme
enfin ça fait marcher du mécanisme dans
la tête ils sont des mécanismes
d'enfants qui sont pas loin de ceux des
expériences que j'avais quand j'avais 8
ans où je jouais aux mousquetaires avec
mes frères et que ce soit ces mêmes
mécanismes qui fonctionnent quand on
joue la comédie et qu'en plus ce soit un
truc sérieux et important est que ça
vous apporte beaucoup de succès et
qu'après on vous demande dans les
journaux d'opinion politique et qu'on
vous donne beaucoup d'argent je trouve
ça absolument génial c'est un métier
merveilleux ça n'a rien à voir avec la
chanson parce que la chanson c'est un
autre truc c'est la fin la feuille
blanche que vous devez bien connaître
qu'il faut remplir alors écrire des
chansons c'est différent après faire le
guignol sur la scène il ya le rapport
qu'il ya c'est ce que disait françois
truffaut c'est qu'on est en danger parce
qu'on est très regardé on fait quelque
chose on essaie d'être intelligent
d'être beau d'être de bien chanter
d'être fort physiquement alors que plein
de gens vous regardent ce qui vous
diminue beaucoup d'être très regardée
alors mais en même temps sur scène on
est c'est une émulation les gens
vous vous transporte vous emporte tandis
que la caméra elle est cruelle elle vous
diminue mais c'est ça le rap